so here you go this is from the
Wonderlic people they're a commercial
company that makes general cognitive
ability tests and it's often used by
corporations even though it's actually
illegal it's actually illegal to use IQ
tests but the Wonderlic doesn't promote
themselves as testing IQ I think they
think it's general cognitive ability
which is the same thing but whatever the
SAT is the GREs the LSAT all of those
are IQ tests so now they're more
crystallized than fluid we'll get to
that in a minute but crystallized
knowledge is what you accrue across time
so you could say that fluid intelligence
is what programs your brain it fills it
with facts let's say it filled it with
knowledge and then but you can get an
estimate of your intelligence by
sampling your domain of factual
knowledge and the reason for that is
that well obviously the better the
programmer the better the content and so
what that also means is that you can you
could if you were did prefrontal cortex
was damaged later in life your fluid IQ
could plummet but your crystallized IQ
remain more or less intact so even
though they're not different one
produces the other and then once the
producer has produced then the producer
can disappear and you still got the
encoded knowledge so I'd love that at
least that's how it looks to me so okay
so how smart do you have to be to be
different things in life well if you
were haven't I give a 116 to 130 which
is 85th percentile and above so it's one
person in eighth up to one person in 130
I believe is 85 90 95 is it 95 I think
it's 95 one person aid to one person in
20 then you can be a attorney a research
analyst an editor dad vert izing manager
a chemist and engineer and executive
manager etc that's that's the now that's
not the high end for IQ by the way you
know that it can go up well I can go up
indefinitely although there's fewer and
fewer people as it goes up so if you
want to be the best at what you're doing
Bar None then having an IQ of above 145
is a necessity and maybe you're pushing
160 in some situations and maybe that's
making you one person in 10,000
or even one person in a hundred thousand
and then also to really be good at it
you probably have to be reasonably
stressed tolerance and also somewhat
conscientious so you know people I mean
you think well why is it that smart
people are at the top of dominance
hierarchies and the answer to that in
part is because they get there first
right I mean everything is a race
roughly speaking and the faster you are
the more likely you are to be at the
forefront of the pack and intelligence
in large part is speed that's not all of
it is so if you're moving towards
something difficult rapidly the faster
people are going to get there first
so IQ of 115 110 to 115 so that's 85th
to 73rd to 85th percentile copywriter
accountant manager sales manager sales
analyst general manager person
purchasing agent registered nurse Sales
Account Executive if you look at
universities the smartest people are
there above this who are the smartest
people at University what do you think
mathematicians physicists and
mathematicians right right I can tell
you who's on the other end but I won't
hahaha yeah I'd like to though anyway
anyways okay going down the now 103 to
108 is slightly above average right 60th
to 70th percentile store manager
bookkeeper credit clerk lab test your
general sales telephone sales accounting
clerk computer operator customer service
rep technician clerk typist so you see
at this level people are people have
some technical skill and some ability to
deal with complex things okay that's
dead average 100 is average dispatcher
in a general office police patrol
officer receptionist cashier general
clerical inside sales clerk meter reader
printer teller data entry electrical
helper 95 to 98 machinist food to
partner manager Quality Control checkers
security guard unskilled labor
maintenance arc welder dye setter
mechanic good-good IQ range for
relatively qualified trades people 87 to
93 messenger factory production worker
assembler food service worker nurse's
aide wear husband custodian janitor
material handler Packer now what you see
in
what you starting to see is that as you
moves down the hierarchy the jobs get
simpler they're more likely to be
assigned by other people or they're
repetitive because what IQ predicts to
some degree is how rapidly you can learn
something but once you've learned it it
doesn't predict how necessarily how well
you do at it and so the more repetitive
jobs ten people with lower IQs are more
suited to more repetitive jobs under 87
is there something well no right that's
a big problem and it's something our
society has not addressed at all jobs
for people with IQs of less than
eighty-five are very very rare so what
the hell are those people supposed to do
it's like one it's 15% of the population
what are they supposed to do well we
better figure it out because one of the
things that's happening too is that as
the the high IQ tech geeks get a hold of
the world the demand for cognitive power
is increasing not decreasing right you
want to be a teller well you know those
checkout machines they're not so simple
you want to work at McDonald's you think
that's a simple job you don't see robots
working at McDonald's and the reason for
that is that what McDonald's workers do
is too complex for for robots to do so
well so this is a discussion that no one
wants to have but that's okay it's still
a problem and it has to be dealt with so
the US government I think I told you
this at one point already it's illegal
to induct anyone into the US Army if
they have an IQ of less than 83 right
it's about 10% of the population because
the US Army and they've been doing IQ
testing since IQ testing began because
they want everybody they can possibly
get into the army because in peacetime
they use it as a way of moving people up
the socio-economic ladder and in wartime
well obviously you need as many soldiers
as you can get your hands on and so
you're not going to be any pickier then
you have to be so when the US Army says
it's illegal to induct anybody into the
Armed Forces if they have an IQ of less
than 83 then you know that they've done
it for absolute necessity right and when
people have made a finding that
contradicts what they want to hear and
there
and out of absolute necessity you can be
reasonably true that it's one of those
facts that just won't bloody well go
away and so you might think well if
there's nothing for someone with an IQ
of less than 83 to do in the army what
makes you think that there's something
that they can do in the general
population and then the issue is you
know because the Conservatives will say
well they should just work harder it's
like sorry that ain't going to fly and
the Liberals will say well there's no
difference between people anyhow and you
can just train people to do everything
and that's wrong so they're both wrong
and they're seriously wrong and the fact
that neither side of the political
perspective will take a good cold hard
look at this problem means that we're
going to increasingly have a structural
problem in our societies because we're
complexify everything so rapidly that
you can't find employment unless
increasingly unless you're intelligent
you guys are really going to face this
you know lawyers are disappearing like
mad and the reason for that is you can
look it up online increasingly you can
do things yourself if you're smart and
so like the working class people are
being wiped out pretty nicely over the
last 30 years by by automation and
various other things it's the low end of
the white collar class that's coming up
next so I'm not saying that lower
lawyers are in the low end but low end
lawyers are in the low end of the white
color class so there's still going to be
plenty of positions for people who are
creative and fast on their feet and
super smart in fact those people are
going to have all the money that's
already happening to a great degree you
know because if you're smart and you can
use a computer you're so smart it's just
absolutely unbelievable right and if you
can't use a computer and lots of people
and I don't mean you know you can open
word that is what I mean I mean maybe I
mean you can program and if you can't
program while you're right at the next
end so if you haven't got that with you
you're you're going to be left behind
a lot of them will take Demerol that's
what's happening in the United States
yeah it's an opiate yeah so there's a
massive drug problem emerging in yeah
yeah no I'm telling you that is what's
happening there yes drugs yeah drugs of
abuse well that what have what is
happening to a large degree is people
drop out of the employment race they get
very depressed they develop chronic pain
problems especially if they're men
because chronic pain and depression are
very much the same thing and then they
subsist on opiates which are subsidized
by Medicaid in the u.s. I'm not kidding
about this this is exactly what's
happening what else is going to happen
to people for whom there's nothing to do
they have a terrible time especially if
they're conscientious that's a good
question you know the AI guys are
pushing hard on this you hey what's the
biggest employment category driver think
about it
what's Tesla doing what all the AI guy
is working on as fast as they possibly
can driverless cars no problem except
that's the biggest employment category
for men so what are those guys going to
do yeah they're going to sit home and
you know be miserable with their wives
and take opiates because they have
chronic pain problems right nasty and
you might think well could they think of
something else to do well if you have an
IQ of 83 or less you're not going to be
doing a lot of thinking about something
else to do you know that isn't how it
works because you're more of a you're an
Act person not a thinking person roughly
speaking you know and so if you have a
task at hand especially if you're
conscientious you can diligently go
about it but you know I've tried to
train people with IQs of 80 and less to
do what I would consider tasks that that
whoa that one of you could learn to do
in ten minutes and never make a mistake
again and it's like tens of hours with
bare minimum mastery of the tasks so
that's ugly situation no doubt about it